proposers I love Jesus sometimes we take
weekend trips together to the beach and
people say but Jordan there are only one
set of footprints in the sand did I say
yes that's because Jesus carries me to
my ATV and then I tear up all of that
Beach
but sometimes the sand dunes of life's
challenges are too big for the ATV of
solutions and when that happens I let
jesus take the wheel we have a crisis in
America and I'm not talking about how
chuck-e-cheese gets all weird if you
don't show up with a kid No while
Democrats try to prevent mass shootings
with meaningless background checks and
age restrictions brave legislators in
Wyoming Arkansas Florida and Oklahoma
are stepping up to actually do something
to keep our children safe look you will
now see in god we trust' display it
across schools all over the state the
House passed the bill yesterday the
representative who sponsored the bill
cited the recent shootings at Stoneman
Douglas in parkland in her closing
speech representative Kimberly Daniels
called God quote the light and said that
Florida schools need the light in them
like never before yes they're hanging
signs that say In God We Trust because
in god we trust' is the part of money
that schools really need this is a smart
solution if we put God's name up in our
schools then he'll recognize our faith
and intervene during tragedies because
as we know when people don't
specifically give the Lord a shout-out
God thinks geez they must not really
want my help
and instead he goes and helps someone
hit a bunch of green lights in a row
thanks for that this morning by the way
but lawmakers in these states knew we
don't need to limit high-capacity
magazines as long as we have
high-capacity divine intervention so
fire up your Waze app Jesus and take the
wheel next yeah clap let's
that was Jesus in a truck god dammit
let's move on down to America's
Northstar Alabama football Bigfoot Roy
Moore what don't they get right and now
they too have a pious idea to stop
school shootings Alabama one step closer
to displaying the Ten Commandments on
public property the state Senate voting
to approve a bill that would allow
schools and governments to show the
religious rules school is a perfect
place for the Ten Commandments it's easy
most of those kids don't even have lives
to covet but of course the cry-baby and
left is wining demanding separation of
church and state but as the child of
four divorces let me tell you separation
sucks it's about time we parent trapped
these touchstones of society back
together because according to state
senator Jared dial if you had the Ten
Commandments posted in a prominent place
in school it has the possibility to
prohibit some student from taking action
to kill other students yes
kids need reminders make your bed do
your homework don't shoot anyone it's a
fact the Lebs refused to accept almost
every homicide happens at a location
without a don't murder sign just a fact
so Jesus put on your Carrie Underwood
playlist and take the whale
finally I want to turn to a group in
Pennsylvania who's taking action on guns
by rounding them all up and bringing
them to church they entered wearing
crowns and carrying ar-15 rifles members
of sanctuary Church in Wayne County say
they're following God's will to honor
the Second Amendment the mass marriage
and blessing ceremony was led by Pastor
Shawn moon he and his followers believe
the ar-15 symbolizes the rod of iron in
the Bible's book of Revelation church
members summon army fatigues sing the
national anthem and when prompted place
their weapons on their laps muzzles
pointing at the ceiling yeah hey God you
better listen to those prayers because
they're aiming right at you this great
idea was brought to you by the world
peace and unification sanctuary which
sure many people refer to as a cult but
leave it to a free-thinking religion to
realize that bringing firearms to church
doesn't just protect people it also
protects the real victims guns if we
wrap our weapons in the impenetrable
armor of the Lord they're untouchable
the Second Amendment inside the First
Amendment inside property rights it's a
constitutional turducken
yes so no not even some team protesters
can take them away everyone is saying we
need to protect our kids from guns but
we need God to protect our guns from
kids so if you want to save your guns
baptize them give them communion heck
let guns be priests so long as they're
not married or female so relax opposers
we don't need to change our stance on
guns or even lift a finger
we just need to lift our hands in prayer
and let my sandal clad Beach bro jesus
take the wheel
off indeed
[Applause]
[Music]